tough times don't last always tough
people do
if you've never been in the bottom of
some stuff you ain't never had to know
but all of you that have been in the
bottom you know it all too well don't
you you have an idea of what it feels
like you've seen some kids get put in
foster care you've seen Child Protective
Services come to somebody's house you've
seen kids come to school with less you
might have been one of the kids that
went to school with less you have
struggled to give your kids a better
life than the one you had they don't
hear this
but I'm gonna tell you something right
now you can be successful without an
education
you can be successful without coming
from a rich family I don't care what's
wrong with you you can be successful
just keep moving don't start feeling
sorry for yourself don't spend time
blaming and talking about what happened
to you see whatever you talk about
that's what you multiply and expand in
your life experience so don't talk about
stuff unless you wanted to keep on
happening to you all right when you
decide I'm not going to settle for this
this is not going to be it for my life I
deserve more than this see that will
start making you do some stuff see a lot
of people go to work every day miserable
and all they do is just talk about how
miserable they are but they don't do
anything about it when the challenges of
life come your way you've got to find
ways to increase your sense of
self-appreciation because if you don't
you're bombarded with negative stuff
every day that beats you down and you
will find yourself unconsciously engaged
in self-destructive Behavior if you
don't program yourself life will program
you when you know within yourself that
there's something you want to do and I
believe that all of us were born with a
purpose
that all of us have something that we
are supposed to do
that all of us have some goodness within
us and that goodness gives us a
responsibility to manifest our greatness
and when you know that you can feel it
in your guts and you know that you're
deliberately operating below your
potential you've gotten comfortable you
stop expanding you stop stretching you
stop challenging yourself let me share
something else with you not only is it
possible for you to have your dream but
it's necessary
even if you put through the most
horrible situations either you can come
out using that experience as a better
human being or you can use the
experience to become a horrible mess so
whenever something hurts you
there are two options
you can either become wounded
or you can become wise this is the
choice
the more things hurt you early on in
your life the wiser you should have
become isn't it but unfortunately most
people become wounded this is simply
because they just need an excuse to turn
their own intelligence against
themselves that's all
especially if the world around you turns
against you it's like a storm that is
hitting you
you know you lose someone someone that
you know dies you are gonna get put into
a storm and what's scary about it is
it's it's an emotional storm and you
have no control over it so you're gonna
break down start crying you're gonna
remember bad things good things you're
not going to be in control of your
emotions which is very difficult for
adults because we're used to having some
level of control over our emotions so
for a period of time you're gonna get
hit with waves of emotion that you have
no control over and they're gonna knock
you off your feet and you're not gonna
be able to finish the sentence you're
gonna it's very very difficult but over
time that storm is going to fade a
little bit and those those waves are
going to get weaker when life knocks
your butt down I want you to get up and
I want you to go heavy on it when Life
deals you a challenge that you didn't
expect I want you to get your butt up
and I want you to go heavy on it the
lesson was when life dishes you a
circumstance that you can't control I
want you to get your butt up and I want
you to go heavy on it I just want one
thing from you today every single day in
the midst of the opposition in the midst
of the challenge in the midst of the
adversity to first and foremost never
forget that we don't burn out in life
because of what we do we burn out in
life because life makes us forget why we
do it second I want you to get up and I
want you to go happy on it at times of
hell
even the hardest men in times of
suffering what we do is we forget how
hard we really are because that's what
suffering is suffering is a test it's
all it is
suffering is a true test of life this is
a race that you run completely alone
and you're all by yourself I'm training
my mind and my body my spirit so it's
all one so I can handle what life is
gonna throw at me because the life I've
lived it throws a whole bunch at you and
if you're not physically immensely
prepared for that
you're just gonna crumble and you're
good for nobody and then you put a goal
in your mind how are you gonna feel man
when you accomplish this goal coming
from that
a lot of people start from a good
starting point they have a good
foundation what if you can surpass all
the
if everybody who was way up here started
up here and you had you started with no
legs you had to grow legs to even start
walking and then crawling and then
running and then you start passing
people and all this given to them I had
to use all this negative
that was making me weak and horrible as
a person I had to use this as a
power that now a few of them had to flip
it on his head and say hold up this
might be exactly what I need the
darkness is exactly what I need is how
you look at your situation quit tripping
during the process oh Lord why me you
ain't the only one oh Lord why me you
ain't the only one that is a blessing in
everything behind every moment of
adversity in your life there is a
blessing and a lesson
every moment of adversity has those two
things pain always leaves a gift
it's not going to change for you it's
covered for everybody say just you
because you got to change your career
maybe it was time for you to move on
when a dog gets shut
all you gotta do is walk up the hall
it's more dose
if you look in life and just step
outside for a minute and quit tripping
it really ain't no problem enjoy every
aspect of life and don't waste any
experience
because I feel like for most of us we
enjoy the good parts right and for most
of us most days are good days
right but
we often waste experiences that don't
show up or turn out the way that we want
them to
and I feel like that's a big mistake
because in those experiences are some of
the greatest lessons and the greatest
opportunities to shape and mold us into
beautiful people
right and so when I say enjoy every
aspect of life enjoy everything UPS down
successes failures highs lows like
everything right because in the end it's
the culmination of all of that that
shapes who they will become and so enjoy
all of it don't waste any of it man when
the days where it's great celebrate it
days when it's not celebrate it might be
hard but celebrate it but everything
passes with time right and so I just
tell them enjoy every aspect of life and
don't waste experiences some people
they're just Fighters man have you ever
seen them people with a never die spirit
like them people no matter how tough it
gets they're gonna be there and they're
gonna scrap them people no matter how
tough it gets they're gonna show up
every single day and be positive those
people no matter the opposition and
adversity they're gonna keep showing up
day by day pressing the opposition
pressing the opposition because the
thing about it is we can't calm the
storm we might as well stop but we can
come our spirit in the in the storm will
stop because every storm has an
expiration date and the beauty of it
when we look back on this covet period
is going to be people that's going to
look back on it and say man because of
Corona because of covet I couldn't
produce on a level that I was capable of
producing that I couldn't do this it
prevented me from doing this and then
you're going to see people on the other
side of it the eight percent that's
going to look back at it and say because
of covet I tap into an element of myself
that I didn't even know I possessed